you know one of the the biggest funders
on the left is george soros
george soros is this crazy radical lib
financier and he's funded all sorts of
terrible left-wing candidates and right
now in particular he's funding
prosecutors
all across america who don't prosecute
crime
so there are prosecutors who are
installed
at
dear cost to george soros who will let
the criminals off the hook and this is
leading to spikes in crime all over the
place one of those prosecutors in
particular is steve discano he's in
fairfax county in virginia
and steve discano is very very upset
because
a
a an official in the yunkan
administration called him out for being
on the payroll of george soros
aka cleary says
well criticize soros funded prosecutors
what's your reaction to that
well i think that that is an unfortunate
way to frame this because when we are
trying to have a discussion about a
substantive matter especially about
crime like you and i are having right
now nick for one party to go and
immediately get off topic and bring up
george soros is unfortunately a tried
and true
anti-semitic trope that has been used in
this country
sin or a decade over decade after decade
when we're trying to talk about crime
and one part of that conversation
immediately goes
to a conspiracy about a shadowy cabal of
foreigners who are pulling strings
to destroy american culture
that is not a good faith argument it's
anti-semitic it's anti-semitic it's a
conspiracy theory george soros isn't
funding anybody he's not funding these
radical prosecutors like me except wait
a second i've got here
i've got here a column from the wall
street journal from about a week ago
this is why i support reform prosecutors
by
george soros there he is no no that's an
anti-semitic hate fact pay no attention
to the man writing in the newspaper
whose name is actually george soros and
it gets a lot worse for this guy descano
right now go to bambi.com
michael when running a business you will
get hit with all kinds of crazy
scenarios an employee not showing up to
work on time mandatory sexual harassment
or workplace safety training wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations one
complaint can destroy your entire
company problem is hr managers are
expensive they can easily cost over
eighty thousand dollars per year but
with bambi you get access to your own
dedicated hr manager starting at just 99
a month all of bambi's hr managers are
based in the united states and can
support the nuances across all 50 states
your manager is available by phone email
and real-time chat to help you
effortlessly run employee on-boardings
and terminations encourage good
performance and make sure your business
stays compliant with ever-changing hr
rules with bambi's hr autopilot you can
automate the most important hr practices
such as setting policies training and
feedback in fact bambi clients are four
times less likely to have a complaint
filed against them go to bambi.com
michael right now for your free hr audit
you run your business let bambi run your
hr b-a-m-b-e-e dot com slash michael
bambi.com
michael
george soros himself in a major
newspaper comes out and says i am
funding radical left-wing prosecutors
who are not enforcing the law who are
not prosecuting the criminals
and one of those prosecutors steve
discano gets called out by a yunkan
official named maggie cleary who
coincidentally actually is a friend of
mine going back to college i'm watching
this clip and it's this usual rigmarole
oh yeah it's anti-semitic it's fake it's
fake news it's a conspiracy move along
and he mentions maggie claire i said i
know maggie cleary she's great she's
terrific totally mainstream republican
great hire for glenn younkin and what
did she say she just said a fact
she said george soros is bankrolling
these guys and these guys are are
destroying law and order in our
communities all around the country and
they're leading to big spikes in crime
especially this guy steve discano he's
one of the worst
he's one of the worst of these liberal
prosecutors
and by the way
he's not just funded sort of indirectly
by george soros and because soros is
funding this movement and other people
are funding him this guy took at least
fifty thousand dollars directly from
george soros through the virginia
justice and public safety pack steve
discano took at least 50 grand it was
probably more than that
the justice and public safety packs are
the mechanism through which george soros
funds these prosecutors soros in the
last 10 years do how much he's spent
unjust the prosecutors
just these da's just these these little
prosecutors this is just one tiny little
aspect of the whole political project
that taurus is engaged in
just here in the united states he spends
money around the world too
40 million dollars
40 million bucks on this kind of a thing
and what has happened
what has happened well you've got
another report here another
news outlet national desk
of this news outlet says two dozen
progressive prosecutors linked to soros
money you saw a chase of boudin who just
got recalled up in san francisco led to
all sorts of chaos up there the la
prosecutor george gascon and a bunch of
others as well what what is this that we
are seeing
it's it's called the celebration
parallax that's the name that mike anton
who's the author of the flight 93 essay
he's at the claremont institute this is
this is the name that he gives to this
phenomenon
which is
the libs tell us that they are doing
something
and they're really happy about that and
they're celebrating that and then the
conservatives just repeat back to the
libs exactly what they have been
shouting and singing with glee and then
the libs
smear the conservatives as racists and
spreading fake news and conspiracy
theorists for saying the exact same
things the libs just said the libs get
to say it and it's true and wonderful
and worthy of celebration the
conservatives say exactly the same thing
it's a horrible conspiracy theory they
need to be
de-platformed it's anti-semitic empty
some as an anti-semitic to read
a fact about this one guy
that he admits in the newspaper it's not
as ann coulter told me when i was in
college when a liberal calls you a
racist you know you've won the argument
i think the liberals know that we've won
the argument they're not even having an
argument they're just saying you're not
allowed to say the same things that we
say
the the phrase celebration parallax is
kind of a
it's a very fancy way of saying it
because a parallax is the the position
of the same object seen from different
angles so you're seeing it from the
liberal angle you're seeing it from the
conservative angle
but that that that is the way to
understand this and especially when you
look at the rate on mar-a-lago there's
no rate on hillary clinton you see
they're going they're going after
republican congressmen for in any way
associating with donald trump and yet
there's video evidence of hunter biden
hunter biden committing all sorts of
national security endangering crimes
they don't do anything about that
it's a two-tiered system
it's a
it's a it's related to the celebration
parallax
the libs do the same thing that the
concern say the same thing well i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm tongue-tied i'm so
frustrated by this
there's two sides to this the libs do
the same thing the conservatives do it's
good when the libs do it it's bad when
the conservatives do it
the libs say the same things the
conservatives say it's true when the
libs say it it's a crazy conspiracy when
the conservatives say you're seeing this
play out in new york right now eric
adams is the mayor of new york city eric
adams is very upset because the governor
of texas greg abbott is bussing illegal
aliens who are being encouraged across
the border by the democrats by joe biden
by the libs in new york and dc and
elsewhere he's bussing them
to new york and dc and all the other
liberal cities
eric adams is furious about that he says
it's putting a severe strain on new
york's resources
it's horrific what what's going on
and eric adams says maybe he's going to
bust some new yorkers down to texas to
give governor abbott a piece of their
mind
i already call all of my friends in
texas
and told them
how to cast their vote and
i am deeply contemplating taking a
busload of new yorkers
to go to texas and do some good
old-fashioned door door-knocking uh
because we
we have to for the good of america we
have to get him out of office
why you got to get him out of office
why what is abbott doing that is dr he's
sending illegal aliens to sanctuary
cities how's that for the good of
america it's a sanctuary city the
sanctuary city the whole premise is you
want the illegal aliens to come but you
don't you just want to say that it you
that you want the illegal aliens to come
you don't actually want them there
because you say that illegal aliens are
really really good for america and
they're net contributors and they don't
bring any crime and they don't bring any
social problems and yet the minute they
show up at your doorstep all of a sudden
this is horrific so horrific you're
going to load up a bus full of new
yorkers to go down there and beat up the
texans and get them to kick greg abbott
out of office
tells you everything that you need to
know i'm glad you liked that clip now
make sure you ring the bell and
subscribe we've now got over a million
subscribers i'm very grateful for that
that's cool this has become one of the
largest youtube channels out there but i
want it to be the very largest i want it
to be number one that means i need a
billion subscribers okay and that's
going to be a little bit of a lift but
we can do it make sure send it to your
friends bing bang subscribe ding dong
whatever you got to do we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]